pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieuse et les épis curieux je
suis sûr que vous avez encore rêver de
porter la couronne
je parle de la galette des rois bien sûr
mais pourquoi les tirs ton au début du
mois de janvier
[Musique]
la coutume existait déjà chez les
romains lors des repas organisé à
l'occasion des saturnales et de grande
fête qui avait lieu au moment du
solstice d'hiver et qui rassemblait
maître esclave les convives choisissez
entre eux un mois à roye éphémère
évidemment ils étaient tirés au sort à
l'issue d'une partie de dae kim do sul
et bientôt dans lequel se cache une fève
n'apparaît quant à lui que bien plus
tard au 14e siècle
à l'époque la fève ressemble à ça c'est
une véritable grève mais pourquoi est on
passé d'une crème naturel un objets en
porcelaine et bien d'après la coutume il
semble que le roi était obligé d'offrir
à boire aux convives
certes un peu trop près de leurs sous ou
parce que la tablette était vraiment
trop grande préférait avaler la fève
plutôt que de débourser leur argent
c'est donc pour éviter cette tricherie
que les fèves en personnel aurait
remplacé les faits végétales
la première aurait été caché dans un
gâteau en 1875 en allemagne aujourd'hui
vous consommez chaque année 32 millions
de galettes des rois au mois de janvier
une chance pour les fabophiles les
collectionneurs de fèves et un regain de
travail pour les dentistes
quand la dent du roi eure trop
violemment la faire le seul qui ne
risque pas de se briser une dent sur la
peine c'est le président de la
république française la galette des rois
est bien servi chaque année à l'elysée
mais aucune fève mais caché à
l'intérieur car dans notre république on
ne peut pas être président est roi en
même temps si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands
en voici d'autres et tourneur
un raté abonnez vous et activer la
cloche
[Musique]